never really meet an ignorant gay guy
now you never made a gig i was like i
only love three things
my truck my gun and dick
you never hear that you know
and i had a guy say to me once hey mark
you like gays so much but what if you
had a gay son
i wouldn't mind having a gay son having
a gay son is like finding a french fry
and your onion rings
you know you're like well it's not what
i expected but
i like these too
yeah
oh boy oh boy i'll tell ya homophobia
that's a weird one honey homophobe's
here
i uh
i did some shows in boston recently i'm
starting this guy after the show i told
him about a friend of mine who's gay
this guy goes you have a gay friend
i wouldn't even shake a gay man's hand
i was like jesus christ why not he goes
you know how many dicks are on that hand
i was like well you shook my hand are
you okay with my dick
because there's a lot of interaction
between the two all right yeah
wow that is terrible logic you know else
touches a lot of dicks
women
yeah man they put them all over you're
screwed
i just got an email from a hot gay guy
this hot gay guy emailed me gorgeous gay
man smoking hot what a bummer i'm not
gay this guy's a 10. all right
a hot gay guy having a crush on you it's
kind of like finding a million pesos
[Laughter]
and now you're like well i can't do much
about this now but once i cross that
line i'll be set